c'était le 24 août dernier l'une des
nombreuses victoires du club franciscain
trophée yvon d'hubert une finale très
disputée et remportée aux tirs au but
contre le golden bayonne chaque année le
trophée marque la reprise de la saison
il motive tous les clubs qui participent
les plus capés le champion de régionale
1 aux plus modestes
le champion de régionale 3 cette année
c'est lui et s riveraine qui disputera
le trophée grand rivière champion
d'hiver 3 cette saison montrent
désormais en r2 on est en attente
mais surtout on est dans l'ambition de
prouver qu'une petite commune du nord
peut figurer par mais parmi les grands
pour nous c'est valorisant aussi de
jouer contre les cadors de la martinique
et de montrer que nous savons aussi
jouer au football dans la commune de
l'extrême-nord de la matinée le petit
poucet de ce trophée n'a pas été gâté
par le tirage au sort mercredi
ils affrontent en demi-finale le tenant
du titre le club franciscain 14 fois
vainqueur sur 21 éditions nous place à
toujours aussi au mieux l'équipe de
grand rivière est une équipe
effectivement que nous connaissons très
bien
jusqu'à présent nous avons d'ailleurs
johnny marr à jaucourt vient de banlieue
qui avec nous il y avait dans le temps
daniel braud valve nous avons eu l'idée
au pôle dit d'avril des bons joueurs
quand même qu'ils sont de go rivière et
nous avons toujours fait bon ménage avec
l'équipe de grêmio moi je pense que ça
va être un beau match
l'autre demi finale opposera le réveil
sportif champion de r2 au golden
laguiole vainqueur de la coupe de
martinique pour la ligue
ce trophée est vendu de berre donne
vraiment le ton de la saison à venir
les joueurs se donnent à fond en plus
les clubs c'est leur première
compétition officielle avec leurs
nouveaux joueurs
et effectivement nous avons des des
enjeux importants pour commander marquer
le territoire et vous savez dans cette
compétition vous avez quatre équipes
mais dans ces quatre équipes trois en
fait fugué honore la régionale donc
c'est aussi un moyen d'affirmer déjà ses
prétentions le trophée ce sont aussi des
dotations pour chacun des clubs
participants quinze mille euros au total
qui permettent d'acheter du matériel
petit ou grand les clubs souffrent du
manque de moyens
le football martiniquais ne fait pas
recette aujourd'hui les joueurs du barça
ou de liverpool sont plus connus que les
choix de notre sélection grâce à la
participation à la gold cup et on espère
grâce un futur statut fifa on réfléchit
actuellement avec le président pirro à
la ligue de football
quelles sont les sources de financement
qu'on pouvait avoir au delà de la
collectivité parce que la collectivité
elle peut pas porter à bout de bras
l'ensemble des fédérations l'ensemble
des ligues et comités sportifs de
martinique
sans compter qu on aurait aimé qu'il y
ait un effort plus conséquent
venant du ministère de la jeunesse et
des sports les finances des clubs
dépendent aussi de l'affluence dans les
tribunes et le public est invité à venir
en masse au stade georges gratiant
première demi-finale mercredi 18h30 la
finale vendredi à 19 heures